[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
alimentation ultra transformée attention
danger
en 2019 5 millions de décès dans le
monde aurait été lié au surpoids et 8
millions à une mauvaise alimentation en
France la culture culinaire permet le
maintien d'une alimentation diversifiée
et équilibrée pourtant 49% des adultes
et 17% des enfants de plus de 6 ans sont
en situation de surpoids ou d'obésité
l'alimentation représente même le
premier facteur de risque de perte
d'année de vie en bonne santé devant le
tabac et l'alcool face à ce constat
inquiétant l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques
lopex adopté le 26 janvier 2023 une note
scientifique de la sénatrice en gel
previl qui s'intéresse à un concept
émergent dans la communauté scientifique
celui de l'alimentation ultra
transformée
les aliments ultra transformés ce sont
ceux qui ont subi d'importants procédés
de transformation ou dans la formulation
contient des additifs non nécessaires à
la sécurité sanitaire colorants et
dulcorant par exemple ou des substances
industrielles telles que des huiles
hydrogénées des amidons modifiés ou
encore des protéines hydrolysées dans le
but d’imiter ou d'améliorer leur qualité
sensorielles les sodas les soupes
déshydratées ou encore les produits
carnés reconstitués en font partie en
France 30 à 35% des calories ingérées
par les adultes proviennent de ces
nouveaux aliments pratiques attrayants
disponibles largement et à des prix
abordables
plusieurs études concordantes estiment
que la consommation de ces aliments
ultra transformés est associée au risque
de certaines maladies chroniques diabète
de type 2 maladies cardiovasculaires
hypertension dépression certaines études
établissent même une association avec
des risques de cancer ou de maladies
intestinales inflammatoires
l'opexte souligne qu'il n'est pas
possible d'exclure l'impact d'autres
facteurs mais considèrent que la
convergence des résultats de ces études
plate fortement en faveur d'un lien de
causalité avec la consommation
d'aliments ultra transformés comment
expliquer ces résultats d'abord parce
que ces aliments sont en moyenne de
moins bonne qualité nutritionnelles
fortement calorique et peu rassasiant il
favorise des apports énergétiques
excessifs et peuvent conduire à une
dépendance alimentaire
leur transformation pourrait aussi
affecter la digestion et la
biodisponibilité des nutriments intégrés
par ailleurs il contiennent des additifs
potentiellement nocifs et peuvent être
contaminés par des molécules à risque
qui se forment au cours des opérations
de transformation
l'état actuel des connaissances appel à
la mise en place urgente de premières
actions préventives de santé publique
estiment l’opex ainsi la note préconise
d'intensifier les recherches publiques
dédiées aux impacts des aliments ultra
transformés dans l'attente d'une
définition scientifique consensuelle et
robuste de ces produits l'OPEX estime
indispensable de mettre en oeuvre des
actions à court terme pour réduire la
consommation de ces aliments programme
de sensibilisation sur les risques
politiques publiques ambitieuses visant
les produits trop gras trop salés trop
sucrés en majorité ultra transformés
ces politiques doivent en particulier
viser les enfants par exemple au travers
de cours de cuisine et de nutrition à
l'école ou d'une nouvelle réglementation
du marketing alimentaire
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]